it's fascinating to me that the the
objective was always the Royal
Shakespeare company and you were not you
were not interested you had no Ambitions
in television you didn't have ambition
in uh film uh and then you know you're
you're doing quite well you've achieved
your dream and then at the age of I
believe
4546 this possibility of this St Trek
show because you you bring up Jean Luke
peard you this this comes along
and you what I always found fascinating
and and you verify in the book is you
approach this as a Shakespearean role
you took it which I think is brilliant
you said oh this is a television show
and this is a you know part of a
generation of you know there's another
Star Trek I'm going to approach this as
if it's Lear or Hamlet that's the
seriousness with which I'm going to take
this and uh it certainly served you well
it did but it also made me comfortable
because I was familiar with that however
when I came to review the first season
of Next Generation I wasn't altogether
happy with the work I'd done I thought
it was too internal too restrained too
solitary too unconnected with the others
so I resolved that from the start of the
second season I would begin to open him
up and let him out and that continued
for seven years seven years and four
movies and then three seasons of Picard
which only wrapped about 15 months ago
it feels like you started to let
yourself have more fun is that what it
is one of my favorite moments in in the
book is telling this because I haven't
told it to many people that uh halfway
through the first season of Next
Generation Um and we were a a wonderful
group of of actors I I fell for Jonathan
and Brent and Marina and Gates and all
of them very s and Lavar and Michael I
mustn't leave anybody out that's it
that's a whole lot and and Whoopi when
she joined us and
um I one day I called a
meeting because I I thought I'm captain
of the
Enterprise but because I'd LED companies
on in the theater I felt
this should be my role here I'm a leader
not just of staffle but of this band of
people who are working these endless
Days 12 14 sometimes 16-hour days to get
all this done so I called this meeting
and I said all right um listen
um what it seems to me you don't people
don't understand is that there are two
sets of of of work going on here there's
the work we do and the time off that we
get occasionally and um you know a day a
long weekend and then there's the rest
of the crew and people in the office who
are here every single day and working
brutal hours we have got to make their
lives easier and the problem is we are
having too much
fun every Christmas season it's the same
thing demands for more podcast episode
comes in and we've got to meet those
demands we got to mail out those
podcasts we got to get them in the mail
well guess what with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that Holiday Rush you
know what I'm saying no I'm just
remember last year when we were stuffing
podcast into envelopes and licking them
and putting on the stamps it was crazy
in here no more not with stamps.com they
even send you a free scale so you have
everything you need to get started cuz
whenever I go to mail stuff out I'm like
where's my scale well they got the scale
ready there for you now taking care of
orders on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a 4-we trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or cont s just go to
stamps.com Conan that was the phrase
that has still not left me today yeah I
mean I heard Jonathan Frank say it to me
yeah I'm sorry we're having too much
fun but you got over that was your
instinct and you got over it yes yes
because it it was limiting yes
restricting you know and and the older I
get as I hope in part this conversation
is
Illustrated I get
looser and and and and I I um attach
things that are inside myself to my
outside life so it's not you
know well there's a it's it's something
it's there's an unclenching that can
happen that's the way I feel of it that
that I that I feel about it which is I
you know even though we're star years
apart
light years apart in so many ways I
have there's my early years where I've
just I've got a tight tight tight grip
and I am just determined so determined
in so many ways and then I find over
time there's this acceptance of flaws of
acceptance of my flaws acceptance of how
silly this all is and I start started to
have a lot more
fun and that's revelatory because the
younger me would say well if you're
having fun the work can't be good and
it's it's completely untrue and
I was intimidated the first time that
you came on the program I remembered I
not met you and I just know you by this
man this man Royal Shakespeare company
and so accomplished and who am I to talk
to him and you were funny and delightful
and self-deprecating and silly and I
think uh that was a real gift that was a
real gift to see that if someone who's
accomplished all this
can can let go a little bit that's a
great that's a great gift to to give to
people thank
you